-You are a millennial mayor
of a town in Indiana,
South Bend.
And you're very popular,
it would seem, by most polls,
but also, I think,
people maybe living in New York
or across the country
don't realize
that's a very diverse city
that you represent.
-Yeah.
-You've had some successes.
You've also had some issues
with poverty, homelessness.
-Yeah.
-What part of being a mayor
do you think is --
will sort of impose itself
on being the job
of president the most?
-Well, I think what you learn
when you're a mayor
is that your job is not only
to come up with good policies,
also to run
an administration capably,
but also
just to hold people together
and to make sure
that you're calling people
to their highest values.
I think that might be the part
that we're most missing
in the White House right now.
And if we want to deal
with our toughest issues,
we have to have that attitude.
So, in a place like South Bend,
still a largely
low-income community
because of the departure
of the auto industry
that started in the '60s,
we've been able
to reduce poverty,
we've been able to put
a lot of resources
into dealing with things
like homelessness.
But you can't pretend that those
problems have just gone away.
And I guess, you know,
at the national level, you know,
the president thinks
that when there's a problem,
you can just say the opposite
and will it away,
whether it's North Korea or
whether it's a domestic issue.
But when you're in a community,
there are no alternative facts.
If there's a problem that
persists from a hole in the road
to a homelessness issue,
you have to just continue
calling people together
to work on it with you
until it gets better.
-I wanted
to ask about this, as well.
During your announcement,
you were onstage
with your husband, Chasten.
And this must have been --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, this is an incredible
moment for anyone.
For anyone to be
with their partner on that day
must be a special moment,
but to think that
only four years ago,
gay marriage was not legal,
did that day have a special,
even added element,
to it for you?
-Yeah. If nothing else,
it's just a reason to believe.
Even at this dark
and complicated and bleak moment
in American politics,
it's a reason to be hopeful.
I mean, running for office
is an act of hope.
You don't do it
unless you believe
that it's at least possible,
using all of the mechanics
of the political system
to make better things happen.
And as somebody
whose marriage exists
because nine women and men
sat and took a vote,
and by the grace of one vote,
we get to be married now.
I understand how
the decisions that are made
in those big white buildings
really affect our lives.
The idea that at the beginning
of this decade, I had a choice.
I could either be out
or I could be in the military.
I could either be out or
I could run for elected office.
At least that's
how I viewed it at the time.
And the idea that
just a few years later,
I announced a campaign
for the American presidency,
and my husband comes out
on the stage to be with me
after I do it, just shows you
what's possible in this country.
-It was a wonderful thing
to watch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is mind-blowing to me.
You --
You are the youngest person,
as of now,
running for president, but more
people are joining every day,
so don't...
-You never know.
-Yeah, don't think
you've got that one for life.
Also, Bernie Sanders
is the oldest person
currently running for president.
When you were 18 years old,
you won an essay in 2000,
writing about Bernie Sanders.
-Yes.
-And there you wore --
That's a -- I would call that
a high school cut.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for sharing that
photo with the American people.
I really appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
-But it must be surreal
to you now to --
Obviously, Bernie was someone
who was influential to you
back then, to be sort of in
the same sphere as him now.
-Yeah. I mean,
I wrote that essay --
I feel like someone
who claims to have discovered
a band before they were cool.
[ Laughter ]
He was an obscure
Congressman from Vermont,
and I just thought there was
something really compelling
about the way he said what he
believed at a time
when it didn't feel like we had
a lot of that in politics.
So I wrote it up,
and I won that essay contest.
It is a little strange
to be competing with him now,
but frankly, a lot of the people
I'm competing with
are people I admire.
I'm not --
I don't view this process
right now as having opponents
as much as it has competitors.
And we can have a lot in common,
at the same time,
have rather different messages
and be very different
messengers.
-My favorite thing about it is,
it sounds like a way
he could burn you.
Like, "I was a congressman
when you were writing essays
about me!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
That would probably be the way
he would say it
if he also
was being nice about it.
[ Both laugh ]
This is a photo
that went around.
Again, you're running
for president,
but you're still doing
your duties as mayor.
Tell us what's happening
in this photo right here.
-Oh, yeah.
This is a really fun one.
So, I got to the office early,
which is rare.
I was knocking out some work.
I stepped out into the hallway
to use the bathroom,
and the elevator opened,
and this couple turned up
and said, "Mayor!"
This is exactly
the kind of moment that my staff
tries to avoid, right?
That I'm alone, you know,
interacting with people
accosting me, wanting something.
But, like, when you're mayor,
you have to have time
for everybody.
-Sure.
-And, you know,
I was trying to be polite
by letting them know
I didn't have a lot of time,
and then they explained
why they were there.
She was on her way
to get a C-section at 9:00.
This must've been about 8:15.
And she said, "I want to tell
mom all the news at once,
so we were wondering
if you could marry us."
-Wow.
-So, I thought,
"Wait.
I can make time for that."
[ Laughter ]
So we came into the office.
I found a staff member
who found some ribbon.
They hadn't had time
to get a ring,
so we took ribbon
and made a little --
made little rings out of it,
and I knocked out, you know,
"By the powers vested in me,
by the state of Indiana..."
knocked out the wedding
in about 20 minutes,
and then sent them on their way
to the hospital.
And later, we got a picture of
them with a really healthy kid,
and we're just
so happy for them.
-That's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I also like -- I like that
an Indiana mayor's office
does look like the set
of "Parks and Recreation."
[ Laughter ]
I do -- I do enjoy that.
Definitely, he's wearing
Andy costume right there.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, everybody,
that's mayor Pete Buttigieg.